good afternoon
i would like to start by
thanking the prime minister of canada
for coming
for coming to spain to participate in
the madrid nato summit that has just
sexually finished this morning
this has been a historic summit and
spain is proud of having hosted it
i'm also very glad and honored to
welcome
you here my dear friend justin at the
palacio de la moncrine what represents
your first official visit to spain
although this is the first visit to
spain of the canadian prime minister in
20 years
it is also our eighth meeting as head of
governments in the last few years which
is
leaving proof of our shared commitment
to push our bilateral agenda forward
so well thank you prime minister for
your visit
canada
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
go
material
so
dear justin allow me to finish by
thanking you once again once again for
your leadership but also for your
friendship i'm very pleased
to have you here with us to keep
advancing our bilateral relations but
also working together
to meet the most pressing challenges of
our time
so
count on spain as a solid ally partner
and friend to work for a more peaceful
prosperous and inclusive
inclusive one so thank you very much
merci
thank you very much pedro what what a
pleasure it is it's been a long 10 days
that the canadian delegation has been on
the road uh we were in africa we were in
in germany for the g7
and here for nato
but being able to finish
with such a good friend with whom we are
so aligned is uh exactly the right thing
because the uh the leadership that you
have shown over the years the way we've
been able to work together on all the
things you've said uh it has been not
just constructive and productive for our
peoples it has not just been impactful
on the world around us
in our bilateral and multilateral work
but it's been a lot of fun to work with
you my friend and i look forward to many
many more years of working very well
together
i want to thank you formally to your
government and to the people of spain
for hosting such a successful and
important nato summit this week
it's more important than ever that
allies be aligned we cannot let up on
the momentum of our collective response
to putin's war of aggression
at the summit we announced that canada
and its allies will augment the capacity
of the nato enhanced forward presence
battle group in latvia a mission as you
pointed out
where the two strongest countries in
their presence are canada and spain in
which uh the
working together that we do is actually
a model for the eight other countries
that are part of that battle group in
latvia we are actually redefining
a concept that is so important to nato
which is
interoperability
making sure that all these
friendly allied militaries who do things
slightly differently with sometimes
slightly different equipment can
actually work together harmoniously is
not just
important to be able to do in times of
conflict and difficult situations
it's actually an added advantage that we
have if we do it right and spain has
been extraordinarily important uh in
that work that we're doing with the
latvians to develop a new way of
operating or a better way of operating
uh for uh nato that could be
unfortunately if uh conflict requires it
extraordinarily useful in the future
unjust unjustifiable war is causing a
steep rise in fuel prices and blockading
critical fuel ex food exports that the
world relies on especially in the global
south and that's making food more
expensive for people in our countries
and leading to potential shortages
for people in the most vulnerable parts
of the world and i have to again thank
you pedro for being
alongside
canada one of those strongest voices on
the need for europe and western
democracies in general to engage in real
substantive ways
in not just
humanitarian or development aid towards
the global south but active partnerships
around investment around creating
greater stability greater economy
economic opportunity uh and greater
wealth
for people in the global south
particularly given the multiple crises
they're facing right now whether it's
economic crises crises related to
climate change
or the crisis of
this war in europe these are things that
are challenging uh everyone around the
world we see it in our own populations
how much more
than the impact on vulnerable
populations and that's where
your voice and others voice in needing
to step up
on
supporting people in vulnerable
countries around the world is so
important we talked about actions we can
take to support people and help
economies grow in ways that provide good
jobs and good incomes for everyone
one of the things we looked at is ways
to deepen the strong trade ties between
our two countries which benefit workers
and businesses in both canada and in
spain
economic commercial global india
the commerce
spain and canada both recognize that a
strong climate plan is key to growing a
strong resilient economy and creating
good jobs now and into the future it's
part of the responsibility we have to
build a bright future in which younger
generations can thrive in which everyone
can see themselves
we know it's a time of disruption crisis
and change for people all around the
world and including in
reasonably
well-off and wealthy countries like
canada and spain there are a lot of
people who look to the future and wonder
if there's room for them
in the future if they're going to have a
career they're going to have
opportunities if their kids are going to
be able to grow up in the same
communities they had
and the responsibility we have as
progressive governments is to show that
a future that is better
on climate that is more fair and
equitable
will create more opportunities for
everyone
because fighting climate change is part
of our work for a better future
alongside the values of protecting
democracy freedom and equity
that ensure opportunity for everyone see
democracy is about everyone having a
voice and everyone having the right to
choose their own future
pedro it was so great to sit down with
you as my last stop on this trip
we are
like-minded partners and friends and i
know that the work we do together will
improve people's lives in canada in
spain
and beyond because by ensuring that we
have strong progressive voices standing
up for equality for democracy and
standing against authoritarianism
and violations of international law
is good for everyone
i'll be heading back to canada this
evening and i'm energized by all the
meetings i've had over the past days
from the commonwealth heads of
government the g7 uh to this nato summit
to this extraordinary bilateral visit uh
which was short but packed as you've all
seen with the communique that touches on
so many things because we agree on so
many things
around the world
we're standing with ukraine and holding
putin accountable for his unjustifiable
and brutal war we're working on strong
economic recovery for everyone that
creates new growth and opportunities
we're accelerating global action to
fight climate change we're enhancing our
defense and deterrence posture and we're
reaffirming and strengthening the deep
ties canada has with countries and
leaders around the world and no better
example than that than right here with
you my friend thank you very much for
all your leadership thank you for your
friendship with us
[Applause]
is